we sat down with a group of people who
lost loved ones in mass shootings to
talk about gun control and other related
issues Stephanie Melendez his father was
killed in the El Paso massacre less than
three weeks ago her daughter who's nine
years old and her mother survived
Sharon Richard's mother and two cousins
died in the 2015 Charleston Church
shooting Richard Martinez his only child
a son was killed in a mass shooting near
the University of California Santa
Barbara that was in 2014 and Elba
márquez's Greene's six-year-old daughter
little Anna grace was murdered at Sandy
Hook elementary school back in 2012
here's part of our conversation with
them that you'll see only on CBS this
morning
Congress and the president have the
ability to act in emergency situations
what more of an emergency situation can
we envision for our country we should be
able to count on our loved ones going
going to a theater going to school and
return safely to us and you know we can
do better than this well the president
seems to be backtracking yeah he now
says you know guns don't pull the
trigger it's the people that pull the
trigger and you hear that and you think
well that's background checks on people
you see what we would like to see I
think all of us is background checks on
all gun sales on this in this country
you know no but with your case Newtown
was different that was something that
just really shocked the core of the
nation because it was so many young
children and people kept saying now
there will be a change in the gun laws
now something will happen
now Congress will act and we sit here
2012 to 2019 seven years later and
nothing has happened how do you process
that I think it Illustrated to the world
that we our Congress was willing to do
nothing and I think that should move you
to action not make you defeated not make
you helpless you don't get the right to
be helpless if I have to get up and
raise my son and and and face the world
with with a dead child a six-year-old in
a bathroom in a first grade then you
have to get up to
and you have to join us because tomorrow
it could be your turn well she made such
a really good point I mean no button
particulars made several good points
they all did during the conversation but
she said it's the hell lottery yeah it's
a whole lot of yes that we are all
playing and that any day any day at any
time it could be any one of us and that
really struck me when she said that it
was such a wide-ranging conversation of
course very emotional as you might
expect we talked about forgiveness
should we be allowed to see the bodies
the damage that was done again Noba said
the Sandy Hook shooter they went and
they looked in that classroom and
everything was removed that the the
firepower was so intense it destroyed
the toilets the porcelain toilets
so she said think about if it destroyed
a porcelain toilet what it did to those
little children yes talking to the the
latest victim of the club that nobody
wants to be in she's still in shock
she's still in a fog and they were
giving her they were giving her advice
on how she could cope president Trump
just yesterday told our Paula Reid at
that Chopper talk there at the end that
he considers gun violence a national
emergency so the time may come soon when
we clarify what those policy should be a
lot of people hope so and what these
parents show is that the consequences of
each one of those individual shootings
keeps going for the rest of their life
affects a lot of people that affects
hundreds thousands of people they are
not the only victims here we'll bring
you more of that emotional conversation
with the loved ones of the mass shooting
victims next week only on CBS this
morning